good morning Hank it's Tuesday today
I'll be reviewing the mobile version of
the famous board game Monopoly I hadn't
played Monopoly in a number of years
before downloading the app and what I'd
forgotten or maybe just never noticed is
that monopoly is a terrible game
the basic idea you buy property and then
charge rent when your opponent lands on
that property leads to a game that is
distressingly similar to real
contemporary human life monopoly unfolds
slowly at first and very quickly at the
end people find meaning and its outcomes
even though it's mostly random and it's
only occasionally fun the mobile game
brings all the terrible things about
monopoly to your phone while adding some
new additional terrible things consider
for instance rich uncle Pennybags who
plays a minor role in the board game but
here shows up to introduce you to
monopoly every single time you play also
since you can't play online with friends
or enemies you're forced to play against
it not particularly intelligent
artificial intelligence and when the AI
begins to lose it quickly becomes
desperate proposing on each turn
increasingly ludicrous trades in an
attempt to acquire properties you have
to decline these trades over and over
and after a while you start to feel
guilty because the only thing this
artificial intelligence has been told to
do is win it monopoly and so now it's
failing at literally its only goal
whereas you a thinking feeling human
have a variety of passions and
fulfillments outside this mobile game so
sometimes you just end up agreeing to
the ridiculous trades to make the AI
happy even so you usually win eventually
but you can't even enjoy it properly
because you feel so sorry for the sad
little artificial intelligence kitten or
maybe that's just me anyway by far the
worst thing about monopoly both the
board game and the mobile app is its
convoluted self contradictory analysis
of capitalism like the game is
essentially about how acquiring land and
the ability to exploit monopolies is
literally a roll of the dice and yet the
game also celebrates getting rich I mean
the only way to win is to bankrupt your
opponents and this turns out to be
partly a product of monopolies
complicated origin story so in 1935 a
door-to-door salesman named Charles
Darrow sold his board game Monopoly to
the company Parker Brothers the game
became hugely successful Darrow was the
first board game millionaire and his
story embodied the American dream a rags
to riches tale of an American inventor
who became successful via his individual
genius and hard work today there's a
plaque celebrating Darrow on the
boardwalk in Atlantic City and Parker
Brothers often prints his heroic story
alongside the game's instructions
there's just one
problem which is that Charles Darrow did
not invent monopoly 30 years earlier a
woman named Elizabeth Meiji invented a
board game called the landlord's game
and although it was in many ways similar
to the monopoly we played today it was a
more direct attack on land monopolize
amande an exploration of how over time
capital tends to become concentrated in
fewer and fewer hands she patented the
game and even tried to sell it to Parker
Brothers but they passed still the
landlord's game became popular in
progressive circles and was even used as
a teaching tool at the University of
Pennsylvania's Wharton finance school
for decades many people played the game
and changed the rules as they went along
the way some versions of it came to be
called monopoly and then in 1933 Charles
Darrow played Monopoly at a friend's
house and afterwards asked for a written
version of the rules he altered some of
the design patented the game and became
a millionaire and so the story we hear
of an individual rightly rewarded for
his genius turns out to be a far more
complicated story of a woman who
invented a game that thousands of
collaborators that improved by playing
it a story of capitalism working turns
out to be a story of capitalism failing
I mean the game that became so popular
was really created by a community and
the free market failed to reward that
community instead wrongly assigning most
of the value to one contributor who
truthfully added very little to the game
this iPhone app by the way is published
by Hasbro the multinational conglomerate
that now owns the very same Parker
Brothers Company that declined Elizabeth
May G's game only to later by Charles
Darrow as version of course none of this
answers the underlying question which is
how anyone ever enjoyed monopoly in the
first place I guess maybe Settlers of
Catan hadn't been invented yet
regardless the history of Monopoly turns
out to be a far more interesting study
of capitalism than the boring game
itself I give it two out of ten not
recommended Hank I'll see you on Friday